welcome back to cbs mornings we are
continuing our cbs news investigation
into claims that the u.s military
ignored reports of domestic violence
within its ranks roughly 100 thousand
incidents of domestic abuse have been
reported to the military since 2015. now
during that time the pentagon spent more
than a billion dollars on a program
meant to help the survivors even so
military spouses partners and service
members told us
their reports of abuse were dismissed
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor nora o'donnell spoke with an
advocate who's worked with hundreds of
survivors she says the resources offered
by the pentagon are just not enough and
the consequences are dire
i realized there wasn't a lot of help
so i decided to just do this myself
before lisa colella became an advocate
for domestic violence victims she
managed a restaurant in north carolina
near camp lejeune
in 2013 her staff started coming to her
about problems at home after their
spouses returned from deployments they
were angry that they were drinking more
that they were blocking them out of bank
accounts that all they had was their
tent money to feed their children how
many of the servers were military
spouses
probably out of a hundred
seventy five eighty how many of them
told you they had been
victims of domestic violence
i would say about half depending on the
type of violence half half absolutely
and maybe more
lisa quit her job at the restaurant and
started her organization healing
household six do you think victims are
safe after they report it
i don't
in fact cbs news spoke with nearly 40
survivors who reported abuse to the
military
many feared for their safety did you
feel like you were in danger after you
reported what happened
yes
yes i still feel in danger after
allegations of domestic violence are
reported dod policy requires commanders
to tell victims about resources but the
survivors we spoke to said that didn't
happen there was no protection for me
there was no help there was no resources
victims have needs and they need to get
what they deserve in terms of mental
health and support
financial situations
you know this is a pretty extensive
epidemic the military does have a
program designed to support victims of
abuse it's called the family advocacy
program but our reporting found it
hasn't lived up to its mission they did
nothing but
support him as the service member even
though i'm also a service member they
weren't
supporting me at all and they were
talking to both of us so i would
literally be in these meetings and it
was like listening to him
she was using his words and it
just was traumatizing
survivors lisa has worked with told her
the same
i've never had anyone report to me that
they received any type of help with
moving
any type of help with food assistance
any type of help with just getting a
protection order i don't think the
program is useful at all the military
also offers domestic violence survivors
a benefit called transitional
compensation it's a stipend intended to
help victims pay for basic living
expenses after they leave an abusive
home
all of the 700 people that i've spoke to
i've only known two that have said that
they even qualified for it and only one
that could show me a record of payment
it's pretty hard to get assistance from
what i can tell yes you only get the
compensation if your spouse is convicted
of some type of assault or domestic
violence and were removed from the
military so the criteria is almost
impossible to me all right
commanders decide if a case will go to
court marshall of the nearly 40
survivors we spoke to
none saw their case move forward to
trial if commanders are going to accept
the responsibility and take the
limelight
they need to do the job and they're not
doing the job well you've got a closed
system that's allowed to police itself
with the commander's discretion
situation or scenario
you know that individual sees a version
of my abuser every day a work self
i got the version at home
that scares me
lisa's organization has helped hundreds
of victims she's only seen two cases go
to a court martial
are offenders being held accountable no
in my experience no sounds like it's
being tolerated all the time and what
are the consequences of that this is
significant trauma
women who are abused have a very
difficult time
seeking employment staying with
employment there's the consequence of
losing health care
there's the consequence of not being
able to support your children and having
them taken from you survivors told us
they're still dealing with the trauma
it's mostly the nightmares and waking up
at night not being able to have
relationships because i'm terrified i
just have
anxiety all the time
i'll never be the person i was before i
met him this is an issue and it's no
longer something that needs to be swept
under the rug
stop aiding and abetting criminals
the pentagon acknowledges they have work
to do in a statement to cbs news defense
secretary lloyd austin told us president
biden has placed an unprecedented
priority on tackling this problem
for cbs mornings i'm nora o'donnell in
washington
and we want you to know you can read
their full statement on the website but
it has to be got such a helpless feeling
to report it and think now i'm going to
be safe and still not feel safe even
after you report it no doubt about it
and we hear that justin justice reforms
are on the way to help these women so
they're not described as victims or
survivors but that's just the first
layer i think they also need to
encourage men and women that might have
the propensity for domestic violence to
seek the help that they need um and
offer therapy to them yeah nice of you
to say men or women but you see all
women sitting there unfortunately this
is mostly men do no doubt about it such
a good point men need to be involved in
this conversation and you can see more
of that investigation tonight on the cbs
evening news norris sits down rather
with a former army attorney who work
with dozens of survivors and calls this
a crisis